on va avoir tout de suite un extrait de
la première pièce c'est à quelle heure à
partir de 22h20 que moi 21h c'est à dire
vraiment dans quelques dizaines de
minutes le soulier de satin de claudel
on voit un extrait finaux seront l'une
des interprètes ludmila mikaël là où il
ya le plus de joie
comment soir je suis absente la wii elle
flux de joie c'est là qu'il ya le plus
cruel je veux est avec toi dans le
principe je veux épouser la cause je
veux apprendre avec lui à ne rien
réservé cette chose tout bord les
toutous données qui nous réserve rien et
à qui l'on france où rodrigue
non mon coeur mon amour oh c'est dieu
qui me remplit la force par laquelle je
t'aime n'est pas différente de celle par
laquelle qu'il existe je suis unis pour
toujours a fait chose qui te donne la
vie éternelle
le sens l'ait pas plus ni à la chair que
dieu ne me fait sentir chaque battement
de son coeur dans ta poitrine qui à
chaque seconde de la bienheureuse
éternité s'unit et se recycle parole
au delà de la mort que je comprends à
peine je te regarde cela me suffit aux
prouesses mais aura pas de moi reste
vivante un extrait du soulier de satin
de claudel